hey leute hier ist doktor watson von den
unglaublich vielen naturphänomenen die
wir auf unserem heimatplaneten
beobachten können von den normalen
dingen die regenbögen oder
sonnenuntergängen bis hin zu total
verrückten sachen wie blauer lava einem
leuchtenden mehr oder unter wasser
kornkreisen von all diesen dingen sind
polarlichter wahrscheinlich das schönste
naturphänomen mit ausnahme vielleicht
von der dank seiner landschaft in china
man ist das schön
doch wer jetzt gerne aber wie entstehen
eigentlich polarlichter und wo kann man
sie beobachten
wie so oft beginnt die antwort auf
unsere frage mit unserer sonne der
riesige heiße ball im zentrum unseres
sonnensystems schreibt nämlich nicht nur
das licht und die wärme aus von denen
wir leben im inneren der sonne ist es so
heiß dass wasserstoff und helium nicht
in normalen aggregatzuständen vorliegen
sondern zu einer heißen masse
verschmelzen zu plasma plasma ist ein
zustand von materie in diesem zustand
sind atome so heiß und haben so viel
energie dass sie sich in ihre
einzelteile auflösen in protonen
neutronen und elektronen und manchmal
sogar noch kleinere teilchen und obwohl
man plasma hier auf der erde höchstens
für ganz kurze zeit in blitzen vorfindet
bestehen geschätzt 99,999 prozent des
universums aus plasma das plasma in der
sonne bleibt aber nicht immer da wo es
herkommt in regelmäßigen abständen
treten große mengen plasma aus zum
beispiel bei riesigen sonnen rekord
aktionen
das sind ausbrüche auf der
sonnenoberfläche die um ein vielfaches
größer sind als die erde selber dabei
werden milliarden kleiner geladener
teilchen raus ins weltall geschleudert
mit circa 400 bis 600 kilometern pro
sekunde
das ist einmal quer durch deutschland in
einer sekunde fliegen die protonen und
elektronen durch den weltraum und ein
kleiner teil davon trifft natürlich auch
die erde
bei größeren sogenannten sonnenwind und
fliegt dabei eine ungeheure energie auf
die erde zu und wenn wir keine
schutzschilde hätten die uns vor dieser
kraft schützen würden dann würde es hier
auf der erde ganz anders aussehen aber
physik sei dank haben wir solche
schilder das magnetfeld der erde ist zum
beispiel so 1 es geht von unserem
flüssigen erdkern aus und lenkt die
geladenen teilchen der sonne um unsere
erde herum
das funktioniert wie bei 2 gleich
geladenen magneten sie stoßen sich
gegenseitig ab das bedeutet auch dass
das magnetfeld der erde verformt wird
und zwar von der sonne weg der ungeheure
druck der sonne verformt unser
magnetfeld millionen kilometer ins
weltall hinaus
aber jetzt wird spannend während ihres
langen flugs von der sonne zur erde
haben sich viele teilchen
wiedervereinigt protonen und elektronen
ziehen sich aufgrund ihrer ungleichen
ladung an wenn die sonnenteilchen jetzt
durch das erdmagnetfeld an uns vorbei
geleitet werden
dann entsteht durch die bewegung eine
elektrische spannung das magnetfeld der
erde trennt die verbindungen der
protonen und elektronen wieder auf und
bewegungsenergie wird in elektrische
energie umgewandelt wenn die
sonnenteilchen jetzt durch das
erdmagnetfeld an uns vorbei geleitet
werden
dann entsteht durch die bewegung eine
elektrische spannung das magnetfeld der
erde trennt die verbindungen der
protonen und elektronen wieder auf und
bewegungsenergie wird in elektrische
energie umgewandelt
die gewaltige elektrische spannung die
nun zwischen sonnenteilchen und
erdmagnetfeld herrscht will sich
entladen
und das passiert meistens schlagartig
das kann man sich vorstellen wie bei
einem luftballon der statisch aufgeladen
wird
elektronen werden von ihren protonen
getrennt und die spannung lässt sich
dann schlagartig wenn die elektronen
wieder zurück wandern beim ballon
passiert das meistens in form eines
kleinen blitzes die elektronen der sonne
allerdings büßten unsichtbar entlang der
feldlinien des magnetfelds richtung erde
und jetzt kann man auch gut sehen warum
die polarlichter so heißen denn die
feldlinien entspringen an den magnet
polen der erde aber die elektronen
selber sind noch nicht das was wir als
polarlichter sehen auf dem weg zur erde
trifft der teilchenstrom irgendwann auf
unseren zweiten tollen schutzschild
unsere atmosphäre wenn jetzt die vielen
elektronen mit hoher geschwindigkeit auf
unsere gase in unserer atmosphäre in 150
kilometern höhe treffen und quasi
richtig in sich rein krachen dann wird
dabei natürlich energie übergeben in der
fachsprache sagt man die gase werden
erregt
dieser zustand hält allerdings nicht
allzu lange an und sobald der regen
wieder abfällt geben die gase die
energie die sie von den elektronen
bekommen haben wieder ab und zwar in
form von photonen und das ist wie wir
alle wissen licht und dieses licht das
die garzeiten abgeben können wir
menschen dann als polarlichter sehen
welche farbe die polarlichter haben
hängt dabei von der art des gases ab
grünes und rotes licht entsteht durch
sauerstoff atome in der atmosphäre
blaues bis violettes licht erhält man
von stickstoffgas und es gibt noch ein
ganz anderes spektrum von polarlichtern
dass wir menschen mit bloßen augen
niemals sehen können wellenlängen im
ultravioletten und röntgenbereich
entstehen nämlich auch es gibt übrigens
an nord und südpol polarlichter obwohl
die lichter im norden bekannter sind
aurora borealis und aurora australis
heißen die wissenschaftlichen
bezeichnungen für das phänomen
aber das heißt nicht dass wir bis ans
ende bzw den anfang der welt reisen
müsst um polarlichter zu sehen
mit ein bisschen glück könnt ihr auch
hier in deutschland polarlichter
beobachten durchschnittlich in vier bis
acht nächten im jahr besonders gut geht
das wenn die sonne mal wieder eine ihrer
phasen hat wenn sie so richtig mies
drauf ist und jeden in ihrer nähe
tonnenweise mit plasma bespuckt
dann wird das magnetfeld der erde
nämlich noch stärker belastet und die
polarlichter sind an vielen stellen
weltweit zu beobachten
klingt erst mal cool bis man dann
bemerkt dass ein starkes elektrisches
spannungsfeld hier auf der erde mehr
schaden anrichtet als ein paar schöne
lichter wieder wettmachen könnten radio
funk satellitenverbindungen all das
könnte ausfallen und es sind auch
teilweise schon strommasten
durchgebrannt weil die belastung zu groß
war
aber wer sagt denn eigentlich das
überhaupt auf der erde bleiben müsse
andere planeten haben auch magnetfelder
und atmosphären und dementsprechend auch
polarlichter der saturn zum beispiel
oder der jupiter der die stärksten
polarlichter innerhalb unseres
sonnensystems produzieren kann und
außerhalb unseres sonnensystems geht
richtig ab
dort wurden schon polarlichter
registriert die über 10.000 mal heller
waren als die des jupiter hey ich möchte
mal was ausprobieren
youtube hat gerade eine brandneue
funktion hinzugefügt um fragen mit denen
ich etwas fragen kann und wir alle
direkt die antworten sehen
deswegen will ich das einfach mal
austesten und fragen was ist eurer
meinung nach das schönste naturphänomen
lava die dank ihrer landschaft
polarlichter vulkan witze oder
fluoreszierende wellen
ich bin mal gespannt wie das
funktioniert ansonsten wenn ihr jetzt
noch zuschaut dann seid ihr bestimmt an
meinem kanal und mir so ein bisschen
interessiert deswegen hier ganz kleines
update ich bereits seit einigen wochen
viel vorher mache viel neue zb hier dem
hintergrund wenig neu gestaltet haben
dass sie ziemlich cool aus ich habe eine
neue kamera ich kann jetzt videos in 4k
abliefern und das alles kostet zum
beispiel zeit deswegen gab es in letzter
zeit etwas weniger videos allerdings ist
das was ich gerade vorbereite was ich
euch leider noch nicht erzählen kann
ziemlich geil und das bedeutet für euch
viele regelmäßige videos ab dann gibt's
dann einmal die woche videos in den
nächsten drei wochen geht es jetzt erst
mal nur ein einziges weiteres videos und
dann ab im märz kommen regelmäßig videos
wöchentlich sogar auf dem kanal hier der
ist wenn euch das video gefallen hat
anlass einen daumen nach oben da und
potter reihe ist